but the big three factors that I think
are explaining to explain part of what's
happening on campus are one the loss of
the unsupervised play so that the kids
have always there's always an adult
present and so they come to college and
they expect there to be an adult and
Dean somebody if there's a conflict
that's one two is social media which hit
just as ijen so I gen internet
generation this is Jean twangy work you
know we used to we used to think that we
used to think that the millennial
generation ends in 1998 or 2000 but Jean
Twenge shows looking at four large data
sets that birth year nineteen ninety
five kids born in nineteen ninety five
and after are really different their
values are different they have much
higher rates of anxiety and depression
especially the girls boys have gone up
girls gone way up and the reason seems
to be that Facebook lowered its age so
in 2005 you had to be a college student
at a certain number of colleges to get
Facebook in 2006 you could be any
eleven-year-old who lies and says that
she's 13 and you've got a Facebook
account but then you're using on your
parents PC and in 2007 the iPhone comes
out and it saturates the market faster
than any consumer product ever has
so by 2010 or 11 a lot of adolescents
have have Facebook and other social
platforms and this is just devastating
especially to girls because it's not
texting texting is just me to you you
know that's back and forth that's fine
you know we when we were kids you called
your fans on the phone that's fine the
problem seems to be according to twangy
it's especially platforms in which you
put something out and then you wait and
see what everyone says it right and that
especially is damaging to girls who
already are at risk of eating disorders
images okay okay so so girls become more
susceptible to negative emotion when
they hit puberty well they're there yes
yes then there's another issue too with
regards to female aggression so you know
it's clearly the case that males are
more likely to be physically damaging /
aggressive than females are but what
females use is reputation savaging
that's Nikki Swick's work Nikki Crick
passed away a couple years ago showed
that if you add it all up boys and girls
are equally aggressive but the boys
aggression is more physical the girls
the more relational so if you imagine a
bunch of 13 14 year-olds in their middle
schools and then you parachute in a
whole bunch of iPhones everybody's got
one in their posture now what are the
boys gonna do they're gonna play video
games that doesn't hurt anybody yeah but
the girls are going to use it to amplify
the social interactions so this is 20
Twinkies explanation I think it makes a
lot of sense so it's a it's a
catastrophe it's a crisis and we're
really hurting especially the girls so
we've got to change something about that
anyway but social media is is possibly
the largest single reason why things are
going haywire on campus the third big
factor and do you think it's primarily
Facebook or can you tell well it's it's
a the kids use a lot of different
platforms but from what I hear Instagram
Facebook snapchat again the thing is
it's one too many that's what's bad it's
anything if it's if it's you put
something out there and you see how many
people like it right that's what's right
and there's always the threat that it'll
go viral and the terror that way so
that's exactly there's the sword of
Damocles limit that's limit or damage
unlimited downside to saying something
so what here phille right so I don't
know if I want to like that post because
you know I could get into trouble for it
right well the benefit to liking it is
minimal and the potential catastrophe
for diss unless you're expected to like
it in which case you better like it
because you if you don't like it you'll
get in trouble so it's a much more of a
mob mentality kids are afraid you know
I'm not blaming the kids I'm very
sympathetic to me these are my kids
they're you know my kids are 11 and 7
they're gonna come up into this so the
kids been raised in a in a social
environment that's much more about mob
mob formation and mob attacks and mob
defend defenses against mobs and then
the so the third factor then is the
political polarization and the
purification or institutions so if you
imagine coming up in the 90s when
political polarization is going up we're
beginning to hate each other more across
party lines but it's not that hard
not that that nasty but it's been
getting much much more hostile so that
now if someone like if someone is if
someone goes to a campus Republicans
meeting if it's a Democrat who goes to a
meeting of the campus Republicans as
happen
UC Santa Cruz a couple weeks ago and
someone finds out you know that so the
the hatred the cross-party hatred is so
much stronger now and many more
institutions are much purer so if you
went to college the 90s there might have
been a few conservative professors
around but now there aren't so as you
said before it's like exposure therapy
if you've never encountered a
conservative idea and then a
conservative like Heather McDonald comes
to speak on your campus well this is
like a major immune response problem we
got to get the tribe together and mob
her and you know shut her down so those
are the I mean there many other reasons
but the loss of unsupervised play social
media and rise in polarization those are
the three big ones